silvio berlusconi was not in court to
hear the verdict the ruling by the Milan
Court has no immediate impact on the
former prime minister because as a
member of the Senate he enjoys
parliamentary immunity but the Senate is
expected to vote next month on whether
to expel him if it does the ban would
take effect Berlusconi would be
prohibited from taking part in any
elections either as a candidate or as a
voter the decision stems from a Supreme
Court ruling on August the first which
upheld a conviction for tax fraud
against Berlusconi linked to his firm
mediaset if the Senate expels Berlusconi
he will also have to serve a one-year
sentence he has opted to do community
service rather than be under house
arrest but Berlusconi still has some
public support we must remember that he
employed so many people I can't think of
any other politician who did anything
concrete like that in his life
immediately after the court ruling
Berlusconi's lawyer said he would appeal
against the ban from political office